ltd negazione lui questo non ci sono a
bizzeffe oggi siamo su pro evolution
soccer 2015 praticamente non è vero
siamo su è più il siamo proprio su happy
meals un gioco che non ho mai fatto
nella mia vita pur di non votare ci ho
giocato ragazzi prima di avere la febbre
15 ho giocato male devo recuperare dai
facciamo livello allora siccome l'ultima
volta non ho capito neanche io che cosa
ho fatto però a fare una roba decente
almeno stavolta sì questa era abbastanza
decente ragazzi credo che il poco non mi
serva in sto livello faccio senza ok
guardarla vabbè vabbè perché arido e
schiamazzo quando posso vincere invece
non vinco moda che merda a lei non si
può fare lega e c'è non so come ho fatto
ma va bene jetpack flight a fight milan
alla battaglia coi jeff beck ma 669 temi
legati per narnia bernardi a ne è uscito
un pene di 4 metri riesco erano allora
madonna mi chiamo infilzato di sotto
tutte le braccia vabbè mi sembra
esageratissimo così semplice come sembra
ecco bravo proprio no ma fa un culo dei
mori ecco sono così vicino che si sta
dando delle schierate che povero
cristiano
ok almeno non soffre più poveraccio sì
sì però non mi devi di minare la faccia
e non è che adesso molto aiutato dai
cheppallle le o le tue braccia se io non
mi capirà le palle bravo bravo devo
andare avanti ho guadagnato un pene
ho visto che culo da farti provare un
ultima volta vi prego se non è una droga
alto livello sei seduto frate minchia
monta avessi mai chiesto il prefetto mai
aveva da portare il kebab vanno a
portare il kebab ma come ragazzi niente
non son riuscito a portare il che barba
destinazione pazienza si salva babbo
natale limitato mi mancano sti livelli e
come sarà
o wwe ragazzi ce la facciamo io ma cosa
che non ho fatto niente è caduto madonna
che malissimo si è spaccato almeno due o
tre cocci di ragazzi devo fare
red un killer in guida io ho detto una
frase che in inglese non esiste con quei
ragazzi ho fatto una mossa che non
farebbe neanche classe ragazzi le mie
doti da john cena lo sapevamo che tanto
ormai ne ho fatti di livelli così che la
metà bastano kill your enemy vai così
ammazziamo chiunque sia
mi sembra il giusto lavoro per classe
ragazzi c non cena che partì incredibile
lo prende
se lo in groppa cosa ragazzi voglio
vedere il replay vista non ride dicono
abbia fatto impossibile del sele
ronaldinho che il canestro è fico è
bellissimo ha fatto una cosa che non
riuscirò mai più nella vita è bellissimo
ragazzi o in meno ma io ho fatto il
video perché sta cosa poi rimarrà nella
storia e secoli baseball straw che mi
mancavano i boltro nel ghiaccio che sono
bigfoot gansu su ok
vai vai vai vai vai vai vai bene rimanda
indietro a giacomo sbloccato la vittoria
perfetto ragazzi mi rimane una palla ce
la posso fare
ci si sporca la [ __ ] baccalà i da
[ __ ] di john cena ce la posso fare che
è assurdo certo livello è una cosa
indecente o le faccio così perché ho
deciso di falso livello a raffica rega a
raffica a raffica qualcosa vincerò prima
o poi non so quando ma non so come né
perché però vincerò effetto
ho vinto non l'ho neanche visto va bene
va bene no proprio no proprio terremoto
e la madonna il cos'è sta roba
addirittura al terremoto riga intanto
sono con nonno ciak
io sono sulla sedia a rotelle che
ammortizza vero zio io sento il
terremoto perché polo
come non detto io posso scendere negli
inferi così c'è anche il colpo di testa
alla fine ragazzi oggi oggi è la puntata
sul calcio però non mi schiacciare
grazie ecco il bidone lo apprezzo
goalkeeper ecco il portiere non mi
riesce molto bene infatti affermi
diciamo che parata brutta
the impossible game come the impossible
bianco la sua piece veramente ma io ho
rimesso un pochettino più di azzurro
perché manca l'azzurro però è molto
molto bello molto vario complimenti dei
the runner cos'è tipo maze runner solo
che non c'è mai stato sembra che store
su un intestino merda vai veloce veloce
maledette palle nostro vivo non so come
ho fatto e serviva un anno sparata
minchia no non ci credo a giro che il
casinò sono io costruivo fermi bye bye
bye bye bye bye maledette palle le
angurie ma che cazzo mi servono
ho vinto cioè non fate mi sembra di aver
corso su un pene lungo dai leaders ci
arriva da bidoni renderle papa fa non ci
arriva ma proviamoci ragazzi non so
cazzi
rock swing imposti porchettato è scritto
imposti con la s quindi già impossibile
scrivere questa era spaccata migliore
che è già in mente e non sono neanche
morto fantastico e dove cazzo devo
andare spiega centrale sto buco oddio
ciò posso fare tirati su tir attivo a
bravo bravo è impossibile avere si
chiama imposti con c'è un motivo tempo
sia perché ci riesco come cazzo sono
basta non è possibile
kakà si è presa cars che devo scappare
da una macchina lo scaffale amoremio
senti qualcosa nel deretano bene non
sono io inizio a preoccuparti no no no
non 8 agosto da cina mano una mano no no
nel senso da cela fisicamente
aiutaci steve ciao steve addio steve è
stato bello ragazzi siamo mia moglie è
stata inglobata da una macchina sembra
che goda ancora però justin bieber
domino
ma cos'è quel contro justin bieber
domino su ok c'è un modo per quindi devo
fare si è fatta ho vinto
by the way that you can't id out how che
non posso uscire eh vabbè non importa e
invece sì ho vinto ho vinto
non so come ricorda ragazzi province
chiara dei giorni i livelli su di me ho
scritto fa dj con la giusta creata
apposta per vedere chi cazzo ha fatto sì
livelli vj fallo e muori vediamo se
riesco stai fermo no il nostro fermo per
il tuo scritto avg ecologista kata che
problemi ci è piaciuto lo scherzetto
non sono morto con gli altri così mica
altro che pro funzione ragazzi morirai
grazie me lo segno adesso scherzavo
fantastico grazie zio e c'è un girone
all inferno comunque ragazzi dovete
sapere per tutti quelli che scrivono fa
vj con la j staccata ve lo farò sapere a
breve favi sei un grande voglio vederti
incazzatissimi su questo livello amico
mio che vuoi vedermi piazzatissimo su
questo livello ti ringrazio ma non c'è
bisogno di giocare livello perché io mi
incazzo mi incazzo solo vedendo come è
scritto fa vj porca [ __ ] e vabbè
importante no dai cazzo già che scrivo
che scrivi male fa vj porca put ladra
[ __ ] la chiace la potrò fare io
continuerò così porca di quella con la
trony nota finché luigi non le palle non
mi fa incazzare sulla livello sono io
che sono un po che cazzo succede vj e il
culo duro perfetto che se livello mi
ispira filosofia a livelli proprio
aristotelici quindi proviamo fa vj e il
culo duro 99 per cento in panne o no
scusami era un po più impossibile del 91
per cento quindi vuol dire che il 99,99
99 per cento delle volte io qua c muoio
vero zio mi sembra proprio così
beh c'è un motivo se questi livelli li
chiamiamo fa vj e il culo duro vero
frate vito quinto ok ok ci siamo ragazzi
ci siamo stavo scherzando ci prova
l'ultima volta perché vita
vabbè al grande festa sono arrivato dall
altra parte a casa bene la considero una
vittoria perché comunque io sono bello
ragazzi concluso mi episodio anche
perché ho visto troppo non voglio fare
nomi comunque vi dico ragazzi che non lo
farò sempre perché ho un casino di altre
idee da fare però lo farò comunque
quindi se qualche domenica non lo
vedrete don't worry be happy
spero che il video vi sia piaciuto un mi
piace per già si sa bene basta smetto ho
capito ho rotto il cazzo
spero che vi sia per cento ragazzi cose
che mi è piaciuta strumento mi piace
capace di facebook con video totana
descrizione cosa vorresti discreto non
ci diamo seguito i sei ragazzi non vi
siete accorti mi sono cagato addosso che
ho paura che mi colpisse la testa ma
tanto è vuota quindi non c'è problema
beh ragazzi